who knows who knows
it's been tough for magnus in the last
two two matches
[Music]
this attack shouldn't no work at all
taking pawns busy taking pawns
okay of course he's trying to play
knight g4 and whatever
hoping for some check on the diagonal
but um okay
well what's this he allowed this check
that was not the most precise way
to do it i guess especially because i
just announced it
but this is an 84 but yeah i mean the
king james knight
94 not not a six check
i'm using what no i thought i missed
king h7
i know but still i think king he was
probably also possible
yeah takes
check what else i mean he has to try
something yeah
such a lucky guy
lucky and good that's the right
combination
king g7 will come it couldn't be two
half queen c3 now
that's actually completely winning for
black
to forgive even okay
not a bad move the clock 12 seconds
against 4 but doesn't really matter
just came over all the way
what do you play we don't have the moves
f6 knight f6 what this is about
a check
okay we see a smiling magnus
but it's been tough eight games
to win against easy panko it was a nice
match it was
very nice much to follow that was
amazing
so magnus carson will face the